[Musique]
face à l'épreuve ça résonne chez moi
comme les romans d'aventurés d'heroic
fantasy
une quête un parcours d'obstacles et
puis les héros qui réussissent à la fin
en équipe et vous
face à l'adversité à quels héraults
pensez vous
moi je pense à mes héros du quotidien
les managers qui traverse leur propre
obstacles qui font leurs propres
explorations
pour créer leur propre leadership
c'est avec cet état d'esprit que j'ai co
créé en 2021 les exploratrices c'est un
collectif de dirigeants animé passionné
par l'innovation managériale et le
leadership et qui partagent ses récits
d'exploration pour réaliser des vrais
carnet d'aventurés des carnets de route
ce qui nous intéresse ce n'est pas
seulement la destination c'est le voyage
je vais donc vous emmener dans un voyage
mon propre carnet de voyage je suis et
dîna bad est la directrice des services
tertiaires du df j'anime aujourd'hui
près de 2000 personnes dans un
management innovant et autour d'un
modèle de performance durable
auparavant j'ai occupé des métiers dans
le management technique clientèle aussi
des métiers financiers et corporate
je vais partager aujourd'hui avec vous
trois quêtes trois convictions pour mon
voyage
face à l'épreuve on ne réussit quand
équipe face à l'épreuve on ne réussit
qu'en ayant fait son chemin personnel
face à l'épreuve on invente le futur
passons donc à la première quête
l'équipe l'aventuré humaine vous
n'imaginez pas harry potter sont
hermione mais aussi sans ron
l'aventuré humaine la clé c'est
l'écoutent et le terrain je démarre dans
cette belle entreprise avec un premier
défi managérial
je suis tout jeune et j'arrive dans une
équipe complètement en crise en
rébellion en surcharge de travail
est là à force d'écouter en me mettant à
côté de chacun d'entre eux en traitant
les problèmes avec eux au quotidien sur
le terrain nous réussissons ensemble à
sortir de cette crise
quelques années plus tard je suis nommé
à la tête d'une équipe technique je suis
jeune femme enceinte et là il se demande
vraiment comment on va s'en sortir avec
un chef qui n'est pas technique
j'apprends je passe du temps avec eux je
sors avec eux sur les les nuits qui sont
parfois difficile d'exploitation et puis
un soir un vendredi soir nous avons un
grand incidence sur le réseau un temps
de chien et là il se retourne vers ma
chef qu'est ce qu'on fait c'était un peu
le test
est là j'avais le choix soit je vais
envoyer sur le terrain tout de suite
soit je leur disais on fait des
manoeuvres à distance j'opte pour les
manoeuvres je les avais vus faire j'ai
confiance premières manoeuvres ça marche
pas deuxième à neuf ça marche pas et
hilary me regarde chef on fait quoi et
là je redis je suis sûr qu'à la
troisième à neuf ça va marcher et ô
miracle ça marche j'avais gagner mes
galons sur un coup de chance mais
j'étais leur chef qui avait son grade de
technicité et puis vient la tempête de
le temps est à l'obéissance vous l'avez
compris aux règles au protocole on est
en gestion de crise chacun joue son rôle
en quoi on coordonne on collabore on
gère mais ce qui m'a surtout marqué dans
cette crise et dans cette tempête
c'est l'afflux massif de toutes ces
personnes qui revenaient chez nous dans
l'entreprise alors qu'elle était
retraité qui reprenaient leur sac et
leurs bleus pour venir nous aider pour
venir aider les autres un mouvement
collectif qui est extraordinaire vous
l'avez compris de cette première phase
de mon expérience professionnelle
j'ai gardé une passion pour le terrain
et surtout une confiance absolue dans le
collectif
et puis ça a été donc en toute logique
que j'ai commencé à démarrer dès
démarche de responsabilisation qu'on
peut appeler par ailleurs dans vos
écoles entreprises libéré et là ça a été
incroyable est formidable je me suis
aperçu que les salariés prenaient en
charge les sujets chaque matin ils se
répartissent la charge de travail et
définissent leurs objectifs il détecte
les problèmes il nous propose des
solutions un univers extraordinaire qui
s'ouvre est devant moi et puis la crise
qu'ovide arrive et là avec tout ce que
nous avions mis en oeuvre et bien les
équipes sont prêtes elles arrivent à
réaliser tout ce qu'elle faisait
normalement au bureau à distance elle
gère tout et la performance est toujours
au rendez vous et puis en plus comme l
ont appris à travailler en équipe et à
prendre soin d'elle elles sont là elles
sont heureuses et tout se passe bien
mêmes elles vont jusqu à innover toutes
les choses qui arrivent les épreuves qui
arrive dans cette crise vite il faut
absolument qu'on arrive à digitaliser
pas le sujet elle s'en empare elle
traite les problèmes vite honda payer
les fournisseurs plus tôt que prévu on a
besoin nous ok on fait une procédure on
revoit elle réinterroge les procédures
elle les interprètes et vous imaginez
bien que dans ce contexte le rôle du
dirigeant ou du manager qui change
complètement et ça m'amène à ma deuxième
quête le parcours du manager
le manager la clé c'est le courage la
ténacité
l'authenticité
courage et ténacité
on va revenir à nos héros de romans de
tout à l'heure c'est une évidence ils
sont tous courageux tenace
en management être tenace ça veut dire
je tiens mes objectifs je refais si j'y
suis pas je continue je me bats pour les
atteindre la ténacité c'est ça le
courage c'est je vais tout faire pour
être dans mes valeurs et faire respecter
ce cadre de valeur qui est si précieux
parce que quand on donne des libertés
quand on responsabilise ça veut dire
aussi que chacun doit se tenir dans ce
cadre de valeur et c'est le courage de
le faire respecter et puis les héros ça
aussi des petites faiblesses de temps en
temps pensé indiana jones il a peur des
serpents alors un manager parfois un peu
d'autodérision parfois utilisé ses
propres petits défauts c'est intéressant
aussi je me retrouve en turquie à la
direction financière chargée de négocier
une acquisition d'un mode de production
d'énergie face à moi un partenaire qui
m'écrase de sa personnalité de son poids
très impressionnant qui m'explique qui
va faire qu'une bouchée avec monaco
histoire de harvard son anglais parfait
et qu'il maîtrise tout est là je me dis
bon ok vous allez manger tout cru mais
peut-être qu'avant on pourra goûter un
petit loukoum tous les deux
et là j'ai réussi à le faire rire juste
parce que je suis simplement gourmande
et que ça m'a fait du bien cette
autodérision
l'autodérision du manager c'est aussi
l'authenticité
et l'authenticité et bien ça passe par
faire ce qu'on dit aux équipes de faire
le faire soi même quand je dis aux
équipes et bien chaque problème est une
opportunité de progresser je dois veut
l'appliquer à moi même quand elle ma
main d'un problème je ne dois pas ni
juger ni blâme et je dois l'accepter
comme une occasion de progresser même si
ça doit m'amener devant le président
d'edf de lui expliquer que on n'a pas
tout à fait bien le régler en prennent
stratégique avec un membre du parlement
bon pas toujours facile mais c'est
extrêmement important qu'elles puissent
voir que ce qu'on dit on le fait
vraiment
eco finalement à chaque épreuve on
cherche qu est ce qui me motive dans
cette épreuve qu'est ce qui est positif
dans cette épreuve ça c'est de la magie
la magie de nos héros d' aventure et je
vais partager avec vous un petit mot
magique
celui qu'on apprend à nos enfants le
petit mot magique
merci merci c'est le mot magique du
manager et du dirigeant surtout usé le à
busan et promettez moi que dans le mois
qui vient vous allez chaque jour donné 3
merci professionnelles scolaires ce que
vous voulez vous verrez la magie de ce
mot et vous verrez les effets que ça
donne sur vos relations
interpersonnelles faites le et écrivez
moi pour me dire ce que ça a fait et ça
m'amène cette magie est ce que ça ouvre
ses petits mots magiques à ma troisième
qu est la troisième kate et bien c'est
celle de l'espace et du temps ouvrir le
champ des possibles est donc le voyage
se poursuit dans le temps et dans
l'espace d'abord dans l'espace je vous
ai dit tout le bonheur que j'ai à être
sur le terrain et bien ce bonheur il est
important de le concilier avec la vision
stratégique aide dans la vision
stratégique et puis revenir sur le
terrain et faire sans arrêt des
allers-retours pour être sûr que ce que
nous voyons sur un plan stratégique est
vraiment propre et correspond au terrain
et puis le voyage dans le temps à user
aussi sans modération on peut imaginer
un futur positif personnellement j'ai
aucun mal à imaginer le positif pour moi
c'est même voluptueux d'être dans la
tente d'un futur mais pour d'autres ça
fait peur alors on commence déjà à se
dire oui il y aura un futur c'est sûr
après cette épreuve il ya un futur et un
futur positif mais pour certaines
personnes c'est difficile alors on
revient dans le présent le présent
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que je fais dans
cette épreuve quelle petite activité je
gère quelque chose à accomplir
aujourd'hui sans penser à demain et puis
ensuite on repasse dans le passé le
passé qu'est ce que j'ai fait hier et
qui m'apporte aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
j'aurais pu mieux faire et que j'ai fait
hier et puis regarder ensemble le chemin
qu'on a déjà accompli et revenir au
présent et se reprojeter dans le futur
parce qu'avec ce qu'on a déjà accompli
on peut avoir encore plus confiance dans
le futur et c'est cette confiance dans
le futur qu'il faut arriver à gagner
avec l'ensemble de vos équipes et pour
ça eh bien on peut aller regarder une
fois encore qu'est ce qu'on a réussi
dans le passé des dernières épreuves à
partir du coc vide qui aurait imaginé
que aujourd'hui on pourrait travailler
de chez soi trois jours par semaine en
ayant la même performance qui aurait
imaginé qu'on aura plus de papiers à
signer plus de parapheurs que tout
serait digitalisées personnes vous
pouvez aussi aller plus loin à l'est par
exemple chez jules verne qui à son
époque a imaginé des choses qui
paraissaient inimaginables et qui
pourtant se sont produites
donc jongler avec cet imaginaire et vous
ferait des choses incroyables ce que je
veux vous dire aujourd'hui c'est que
face à l'épreuve comme les héros de nos
romans cultivons incroyable
[Musique]